[Music]
on this Monday night Canada's worst
spring Wildfire season the worries out
west and you know your home could
disappear what's forecast when evacuees
could head home and the mission to keep
communities from getting cut off
former U.S president Trump in Florida
tonight ahead of his big day in court
our Jackson prosco is there
chin under scrutiny the accusations the
fast fashion giant sells clothing made
by forced labor
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us it's
now officially Canada's worst Wildfire
season of the 21st century 4.7 million
hectares of forest has burned this
spring and more than 400 fires are
burning right now the world is coming to
our Aid more International Help is now
on the way
couple of days to see nearly 100
additional firefighters from Chile and
Costa Rica and the following day
approximately 240 from Spain and
Portugal
fires have driven more than 32 thousand
people from their homes and in some
communities in BC and Alberta the fires
are just kilometers away Nito Garcia has
our top story tonight
oh this evacuee from the BC community of
Tumblr Ridge finding moments of Joy with
his dog Jake despite fears of losing the
town there's some people that are really
worried because uh we're at that cuff
like like you say things that kind of
seem okay but I know I've worked
forestry all it takes is one of the wins
that got us out of there
it's the fifth day more than 2 000
people have been out of their homes and
local officials say they likely won't
return before Friday it's very stressful
and just the not knowing is very
frightening as well
while there is rain in the local
forecast for Tuesday winds are the
biggest concern
hot dry conditions in Alberta have been
challenging firefighters across the
province it's scary knowing that the
fires are right there and you know your
home could disappear a wildfire now
about three times the size of Edmonton
which forced a second evacuation of the
town of Edson grew over the weekend
local officials say the difference this
time is the fire is within about a
kilometer of the town of more than 8 000
people they're urging anyone still there
to get out now we have asked you to
leave but I'm reiterating this because I
can't underestimate how serious the
situation is
on Vancouver Island a large
out-of-control Wildfire is toppling
trees onto Highway 4 keeping the only
paved roadway to the Island's West Coast
Communities closed a local grocery store
manager says truck deliveries are now
arriving through special convoys there's
a bit of shopping and
pissed off
I realize they don't have to stock up
too much right now run knowing things
could change quickly some residents
forced to flee from Tumblr Ridge are
trying to stay positive everything will
be okay no matter what happens
reassuring themselves as firefighters on
the front lines of fires across
provinces and territories take stock of
their next steps in this record-breaking
Fire season that's just getting started
Global News
[Music]
ankle back the highway into shibugamu
reopened this morning allowing thousands
of people to go home more than seven
thousand people fled last week Premier
Francois Lago says the situation has now
improved but more than 120 fires are
still burning across Quebec rain is
expected in some areas this week but so
is lightning which could spark more
fires
there is no let up in the coals for a
public inquiry into foreign interference
in Canada and now that former Governor
General David Johnston is quitting his
job as special repertoire saying the
whole thing is two partisan the pressure
is on the opposition to suggest someone
better David Baxter reports
in the wake of David Johnson's
resignation to special rapporteur on
foreign interference the opposition
message is clear call a public inquiry
so I want it to be done soon and I want
to be done before an election so we can
put in place Johnston recommended
against the public inquiry but now
intergovernmental affairs minister
Dominic LeBlanc says it was never ruled
out it should have been the first Resort
not the last resort and it's very clear
they have no plan and and they never
intended to investigate foreign
interference in our election when will
they stop delaying this with their games
and just call a public inquiry they're
here so saying they want a public
inquiry right now is not in fact a
responsible suggestion they should tell
us what would be the terms of reference
how will they protect the National
Security interests of Canadians who
might lead this process in a proper way
on Sunday Pierre pauliev said he would
be reaching out to the other opposition
parties to begin talks on what an
inquiry could look like and who leads it
and if they do that the government
better choose from that short list
or the opposition parties will very
easily be able to point that they didn't
and and prove that they didn't finding
one person to lead this process won't be
easy who has the knowledge on operating
elections government process National
Security and a sterling reputation there
may not be an individual a single
individual that meets all of that former
privy Council clerk Michael wernick
suggests a panel may be a better way to
satisfy all parties than a single rapid
tour leading the process if an inquiry
does go ahead it likely won't wrap up
before the next election especially in a
minority setting while the any inquiry
is underway they could be working on
putting legislation in place and
protecting the next election now Pierre
Paulie having jagmeet Singh don't agree
on much but with this issue they do
whoever is next to lead the process must
be seen as non-partisan and have zero
links to the Trudeau Foundation Donna
okay David Baxter in Ottawa thanks a
judge on Canada's Supreme Court Russell
Brown has announced he is retiring
effective immediately and ending an
investigation into accusations of
misconduct the Canadian judicial Council
says it no longer has jurisdiction to
investigate an alleged alcohol-fueled
incident at an Arizona hotel in January
Brown Who was appointed to the Supreme
Court in 2015 had been on paid leave
since February he has denied accusations
he was intoxicated and harassed a group
of friends at the event the 57-year-old
is stepping down nearly 18 years before
the legal end of his mandate leaving a
glaring hole on the nine-judge panel
former U.S president Donald Trump is in
Florida tonight ahead of his court
appearance tomorrow he faces 37 federal
charges accused of retaining classified
documents after leaving the White House
and scheming to block government efforts
to retrieve them the evidence in the
indictment is damning yet senior
Republicans are standing behind Trump
who has called for protests outside the
courthouse tomorrow Jackson prosco is in
Miami tonight
returning to Florida the scene of his
alleged crimes Donald Trump prepared for
his historic surrender to Federal
authorities and arraignment on dozens of
criminal charges
foreign
over the weekend he rallied and railed
against the indictment and the
investigation led by special counsel
Jack Smith which on Witch Hunt scam hoax
it's called election interference his
words carry weight and outside the
courthouse police are on edge Trump has
called on his supporters to protest
groups including the far-right proud
boys have promised to be there we're
taking this uh this event extremely
serious we know that there is a
potential of things uh taking a turn for
the worst but that's not the Miami way
the indictment and its 37 charges stem
from Trump's refusal to return highly
classified documents relating to U.S
nuclear weapons and foreign intelligence
operations there's an obstruction charge
alleging he and his aide tried to hide
the documents he is in more legal
Jeopardy now than at any other point the
federal government is not playing here
this is they've done their investigation
they have their documents they have
their photographs they have their
Witnesses and they are ready to go yet
politically Trump has never been in a
better place
the Chargers have helped his
presidential campaign as Republicans
circle the wagons they're vowing Revenge
if you want to get to president Trump
you're going to have to go through me
and you're going to have to go through
75 million Americans just like me
most of us are card carrying members of
the NRA
despite claiming that his own
prosecution is politically motivated
Trump is now promising that if he's
re-elected president he'll launch an
investigation to go after President Joe
Biden for unspecified crimes he's
currently planning to return to New
Jersey after his court appearance where
he'll hold a fundraising dinner with
donors as he seeks to capitalize on his
legal woes Donna all right Jackson
prosco in Miami tonight thank you
Canada's labor Minister says the
government will introduce legislation
next year to eradicate forced labor from
Canadian Supply chains his statement
comes on world day against child labor
it's meant to raise awareness about the
practice of exploiting children a global
news investigation has found a number of
companies selling products in Canada
allegedly produced by forced labor Jeff
Semple reports
it's the biggest name in fast fashion we
have a giant box here from
the Chinese online retailer was the
world's most popular fashion brand last
year targeting young Shoppers with low
prices huge shine haul and online videos
promoting quality and quantity then I
got this dress so cute then I got this
dress but behind the scenes the company
is accused of making its billions on the
backs of forced laborers we see it it is
cheap it is cheap because it is made by
the forced neighbor this uyghur activist
accuses Sheehan of using cotton produced
in xinjiang China where human rights
groups say Beijing is conducting a
genocide against uyghur Muslims
involving forced labor camps in a
statement a shiin spokesperson said we
are committed to respecting human rights
and adhering to local laws in each
market we operate in we have zero
tolerance for forced labor I decided to
order some cotton items from Shin this
American journalist recently hired an
independent lab to test Sheehan's claim
the cotton from the sheen items that I
ordered matched the xinjiang cotton
almost exactly the US is now cracking
down Banning All Imports from xinjiang
Province Mexico passed a similar law but
not Canada
in fact Sheehan just opened this massive
Distribution Center North of Toronto
sparking a small protest over the
weekend
20 Canada banned the import of all
products produced using forced labor but
so far not a single Shipment has been
seized at the border and Xi'an isn't the
only company in the crosshairs import
records show ingredients linked to
forced labor allegations in xinjiang on
sale across the country from tomato
paste at Dollarama to Red dates at this
Toronto supermarket and gloves at this
Vancouver textile shop the store's owner
says they recently stopped selling the
gloves after learning of the allegations
Canada is a Dumping Ground for the
products made by the use of wigger Force
labor and he says as other countries
shut the door on these products Canada
risks becoming an even more popular
destination Jeff Semple Global News
Markham Ontario
he was both revered and reviled coming
up the legacy of former Italian Prime
Minister Silvio Berlusconi
Ukraine's military claims it has retaken
a fourth Village from Russian forces
after launching counter-offensives to
recapture a territory
new video shows soldiers flying the
Ukrainian flag after appearing to take
control of a village in the Donetsk
region in the country's Southeast
yesterday Ukraine claimed it had
liberated three villages
as rescue efforts enter a sixth day
after a Hydro Dam collapse that caused
widespread flooding in Ukraine's Hassan
region the Ukrainian government is now
accusing Russian forces of blowing up
another Dam to slow Ukraine's
counter-offensive the international
criminal court has opened an
investigation into the initial collapse
which both sides blame on each other
[Music]
largest ever air deployment exercise in
the Skies over Germany 250 aircraft from
25 nations are taking part they'll train
in crisis situations and send a
political message to Russia about NATO's
strength
the Russian President Vladimir Putin is
among world leaders paying tribute to
former Italian Prime Minister Silvio
Berlusconi the controversial billionaire
turned politician died on Monday at the
age of 86. Berlusconi was Italy's
longest-serving leader since the second
world war and arguably created the
template for many populist leaders who
followed Redmond Shannon reports
an Italian news anchor breaks down
announcing the death of the TV Network's
founder Silvio Berlusconi
and air with a permitan and an
improbable hairline Berlusconi leveraged
property wealth and the power of TV to
enter politics starting his own party
focused mostly around his Politically
Incorrect personality
from referring to Barack Obama as
suntand to sex scandals and legal
battles in many ways he was Trump before
Trump was Trump coming though from more
humble beginnings he was a singer on a
cruise ship where he has learned how to
entertain Professor Paula mattei says
berlusconi's greatest success was his
longevity despite his failure to follow
through on many promises his ultimate on
doing as prime minister the 2008
financial crisis which left Italy's
already stagnant economy broken but he
will forever be associated with the
bunga bunga Scandal where he was
convicted but later acquitted of paying
for sex with a teenage dancer then in
2013 he only escaped jail time over tax
fraud because of his age while banned
from taking public offers he visited his
friend Vladimir Putin in illegally
annexed Crimea after returning to
politics his party joined the current
Coalition led by George Maloney his
bombastic Legacy felt by followers but
also by those who never voted for him
Italian
even last month as his health failed he
campaigned from hospital behind him a
photo of perhaps his biggest admirer of
all himself Redmond Shannon Global News
London
ahead the rescue of four children lost
in the Amazon jungle for 40 days
if it were a movie the ending would seem
improbable four Colombian children
somehow survived a plane crash and then
40 days in the Amazon jungle their
family got the news they'd been praying
for as Mike Armstrong explains harrowing
details are now emerging about what they
endured
when search Crews finally found the
children the good news went out by radio
as an alert one word repeated four times
Miracle the siblings were airlifted out
of the Jungle after being stranded for
more than five weeks the youngest barely
a year old the oldest just 13.
the father of the two youngest is
revealing heartbreaking details of what
happened he says Leslie the 13 year old
says their mother survived the crash but
was badly injured before she died she
told the children to leave to save
themselves
claim to disappeared May 1st in the
dense Amazon jungle the pilot had
radioed a Mayday alert due to engine
failure
more than 100 soldiers and 200
indigenous volunteers searched a massive
area about 300 square kilometers the
wreckage was found May 16th with three
bodies the children weren't there it's
believed they were in the back of the
plane when it crashed they survived
because that part was less damaged they
still had to survive the Jungle the
children's grandmother says they were
led by the 13 year old a young girl she
says with the nature of a warrior the
family are members of an indigenous
tribe the children were taught hunting
and fishing at a young age and also
played survival games and knew what they
could eat in the jungle and what was
poisonous
the father says the children are
recovering well he hopes to have his
kids back home soon now the youngest
child has a new Godfather the family has
given that honor to the commander of the
rescue operation it is amazing I just
only have one kid but for me I have in
this moment too
Operation HOPE isn't quite over during
the search the soldiers lost a dog in
the jungle Wilson is missing and the
military says it won't leave him behind
they're still looking this is a drawing
of Wilson done by one of the children in
hospital Mike Armstrong Global News